let's start with that headline which I
think will startle a lot of people Joe
Biden has not declared his candidacy
he's expressed trepidation about getting
into the race how surprise for you to
find this well I think it is surprising
it's better than Joe Biden has ever done
in any presidential poll and he's run
two times before so it sort of is almost
a hypothetical because we don't elect
presidents based on national elections
and terminate them that is so for him to
end up with one out of four people
saying that he is their first choice and
that's meaningful do we have any sense
of what it is about Joe Biden that's
attractive to the people whom you've
pulled is it experienced what might have
been well it could be any number of
things I certainly know him fairly well
it could be that he's the one not
running so he's not been in the
spotlight and and all of that I think
there's a there's just what what i
thought was especially interesting is
that there's not that much difference
between republicans and democrats in
their wish for him to get in this around
between forty and fifty percent saying
they wish he would run over all that's a
different poll number there but they're
saying it would be good for the race if
he got in Republicans might think he can
beat Hillary Clinton and they think
she's more formidable Democrats may
think he's more aligned with my values
he's a good guy he's not tarnished
different reasons such a funny
definitional difference a crowded field
of Republicans with 15 it could be a
crowded field I suppose of Democrats
with with 33 I wonder when you when you
look at the basis or potential basis for
these three candidates Hillary Clinton
obviously still pulling well with women
voters in particular mr. natural base
for Biden or well let me just say that
her base with women is actually eroding
she's becoming more of an androgynous
candidate with almost equal I think
she's got five points greater support
among women than among men but what she
had used to have in terms of a big
gender gap isn't there among Democrats
anyway so she may be polling better on a
general election basis with women and
pulling them in there but that's
interesting to me I think Biden is
really across the board just the kind of
guy that draws across the board Bernie
Sanders we know does better with younger
people he does better with people when
we asked what's your religious
preference they say none we call him the
nuns better with that he does better
with liberals he may be finding though
pockets geographically rather than
having that more broad widespread appeal
and I think
that's what Joe Biden might have going
for him as that wider spread appeal just
ask you Leslie and quickly senator
Sanders got into the race a lot of
people thought he was there to sort of
shake things up is his support growing
is he getting enjoying any wider support
than he had before well this this poll
doesn't suggest that that's the case in
Iowa where which is the first contest we
have seen him close on Hillary Clinton
so where it matters for him to be making
up ground he is our national poll
thirty-five percent still didn't know
enough about him to say how they felt
about him how their feelings were so
he's he's not quite a national figure
yet